mais pourquoi fait-on autant confiance
au gouvernement cette question c'est
celle qu'on peut lire dans vos
commentaires
en réaction à la remontée de l'exécutif
dans les enquêtes d'opinion
d'un autre côté quand on lit vos
commentaires on voit que certains
s'indignent par rapport à cette remontée
dans l'opinion dans d'autres
commentaires d'ailleurs on voit que la
colère monte contre les décisions et en
particulier les dernières décisions du
gouvernement est fondé
est-ce injuste je vous propose de poser
le débat d'abord avec denis olivennes
ancien patron de la fnac et auteur d'un
livre où il se moque de la propension
toutes françaises selon lui à avoir
l'avenir et à voir les choses
on sombre à l'opposé ivan rioufol
chroniqueur au figaro et auteur d'un
livre
auteur notamment d'un livre au titre
vraiment sombre la guerre civile qui
vient c'est aux éditions pierre
guillaume dont je vous propose également
d'écouter d'entendre le diagnostic d'un
médecin particulièrement compétent dans
ce domaine c'est lui qui avait lancé
l'alertent pendant la crise de la
canicule en 2003 le docteur patrick
peloux à l'oeuvre d'ailleurs également
durant cette crise du coronavirus il est
également l'auteur de ce livre que je
vous recommande pendant ses séjours de
confinement
mieux vaut mourir debout que vivre à
genoux il raconte les derniers jours des
grands hommes avec un point de vue
médical
c'est très bien écrit c'est vraiment
passionnant c'est aux éditions robert
laffont je vous propose enfin le regard
d'une femme de tête cultiver nuancé
lucile schmid cofondatrice du think tank
la fabrique écologie je vous propose
d'écouter leurs points de vue et de
confronter leurs opinions avec votre
avis
[Musique]
si vous appréciez ce débat si vous
appréciez cette controverse merci de
nous le dire par un pouce levé sur
youtube et de partager cette vidéo jolie
vos commentaires et il ya une chose qui
frappe c'est que beaucoup d'entre vous
expriment leur confiance est là ce qui
m'a surpris c'est que c'est exactement
le point de vue des débatteurs et là sur
ce plan là le point de vue est unanime
on n'est pas dans une période ordinaire
et que la question de la confiance du
gouvernement repose pas sur les éléments
habituels
on n'a pas vraiment le choix oui je fais
confiance au gouvernement dans la mesure
où je suis reclus j'applique les
consignes à la lettre et j'applaudis
bien sûr à ces mesures qui sont prises
aujourd'hui je crois qu'il faut faire
confiance au gouvernement parce qu'il
faut un chef il faut un chef qui est là
où on va comme on y va qu'est ce qu'on
doit faire
il faut qu'on ait un chef ça a toujours
été comme ça en revanche sur les
décisions il y à débat voire polémiques
je suis moi-même ulcéré je suis même
indignée et même en colère dans le fond
par tout le temps qui a été perdue me
semble-t-il depuis au moins deux mois
sachant en tout cas si l'on en croit
l'ancien ministre de la santé agnès
buzyn qui elle même a dit qu'elle avait
prévenu d'une dangerosité de la crise mi
janvier je suis enrage de voir qu'en
tout cas pour cause de lourdeurs
administratives à cause de l'entêtement
idéologique je parle là des frontières à
cause de de technocratie alourdi nous
ayons perdu autant de temps par exemple
à se résoudre aujourd'hui naturellement
à généraliser pour bientôt les les
masques quand on en aura à généraliser
les tests quand on en aura et et enfin à
comprendre qu'il fallait également des
respirateurs kiss à l'ailé sur blues etc
enfin tout ce qu'ils auraient quand même
pu être prévu me semble-t-il d'un
gouvernement si en tout cas le gouverner
c'est prévoir
mais c'est plus facile d'avoir su plus
ou moins introspectif que de décider sur
le moment donc oui j'ai l'impression que
le gouvernement et les experts qui
l'entouré d'administration prenne les
mesures qui doivent être prises sur les
décisions aussi on entend de plus en
plus un point de vue et là il met en
cause la place la prépondérance des
scientifiques ont fini par dire
le gouvernement gouverne parce qu'on a
l'impression que on a l'impression qu'il
ya une dictature médical qui est apparu
qui a pris le pouvoir en france et qui
fait un petit peu ce qui m e
à titre d'exemple les institutions
démocratiques qui existe dans les
hôpitaux ont été mises entre parenthèses
au profit de cellule de crise avec des
professeurs j'ai notamment dans les chu
qui ont été nommés souvent
d'anesthésie-réanimation qui ont pris le
pouvoir et s'est appuyé pouvoir
autocratique où on ne peut pas parler
discuter se rassembler et changer donc
c'est très bien d'avoir associé les
scientifiques d'ailleurs ne sont pas
toujours d'accord entre eux je tiens à
dire à la décision mais que la décision
doit rester une fine et celle de ceux
qu'on a t on qu'on a élu puisque de
toute façon nous sommes en démocratie
excellent à la décision politique
appartient évidemment à ce qu'on a et
l'hymne est parti à man au gouvernement
alors sur la crise de confiance qui se
profile que doit-il en sortir là encore
nos débatteurs ne sont pas d'accord je
pense que la contestation est en train
de se formaliser et grandi avec ce
qu'ils font pas du tout confiance parce
qu'il se dit en fait ce cette crise
sanitaire va leur permettre de faire
passer des tas de mesures de réforme qui
de dons dont le pays n'a pas envie je
suis plutôt inquiet suite des événements
parce que il sera très facile incriminés
à tort à mes yeux la mondialisation
comme si les virus n'existait pas avant
la les épidémies n'existait pas avant la
mondialisation le néolibéralisme comme
si la france était un pays les néo
libéral lors que la 56 % de dépenses
publiques dans son pib
les élites toujours coupable et
responsable et donc on voit bien que ces
thèmes-là très inflammatoire qui
consiste à donner des explications trop
simple de phénomènes complexes vont
avoir le vent en poupe
je me demande si au sortir de cette
crise on ne demandera pas
nos gouvernants à ce qu'on est et qu'on
a élu des qualités différentes en tout
cas une relation différente par rapport
à la réalité de nous dire davantage la
réalité avec les incertitudes que ça
suppose et donc de nous prendre
peut-être nos sociétés civiles pour des
adultes mais je crois que l'heure des
comptes arrivera et dans leur décompte
qui arrivera le gouvernement aura à
s'expliquer sur beaucoup de ses
manipulations en tous cas où de ces
désinformations de ces abus de confiance
c'est me semble-t-il aller avant de se
quitter je vous propose de vous rendre
sur la page facebook du figaro et de
retrouver ce fac tu signé stéphane
foltzer il revient en détail sur ce que
cache vraiment la remontée de la
popularité des mails macron du premier
ministre de l'éxécutif surtout sur
l'ampleur d'un phénomène mise en lumière
par les éclairages de jérôme
sainte-marie et d'emmanuel rivière
le nombre de gens qui ne font pas qu'ils
ne font plus confiance au président et
qui ne partagent plus son avis
[Musique]